hi in this module i'm going to talk
about k-means a simple algorithm for
clustering
one form of unsupervised learning
so i want to start with a classical
example of clustering from the nlp
literature around clustering
so this was the
unsupervised learning method of choice
before word vector
or contextualized word
so on so the input to the algorithm was
simply raw text lots of lots of words of
musicals and the output was a clustering
of those words
um so
the algorithm was able to pick out a
cluster one which
friday monday thursday and generally
days of the week a certude had months
um cluster three had some sort of
natural resources
and you can list and each cluster had
fairly coherent
uh
structure
in it
one thing that's
quite interesting to note is that no one
told this algorithm
what days of the week were or what
months or what family relations are it
was able to simply figure all the stuff
out just by looking at the data
so on a personal note brown clustering
was actually my first experience that
got me to pursue research in nlp in the
first place just seeing the results of
unsupervised learning uh when it worked
was kind of really magical
and of course today we're seeing even
more strong evidence of the sheer
potential of unsupervised learning with
a language
for attention
so
i want to contrast
to unsupervised learning and supervised
learning
so in
supervised learning we looked at
classification you're given a training
set which is labeled
so
inputs are labeled with an output y
this goes into a learning algorithm you
get a classifier and then you click on
new points
and
the main challenge with on the label
data is that label data is expensive to
obtain you have to have
annotated
often domain experts add
so in contrast
unsupervised learning um
of which clustering is a form of
is uses on label data that's very cheap
to obtain
so as a concrete example suppose you
have uh some points
here
and they're just unlabeled points
um
any data can be sizes here there's
points
um and we want a learning algorithm
that can produce
not a predictor but
an assignment of each point uh to a
cluster i have two clusters
so let's assign the first
uh four points um the blue cluster
here are the four points blue cluster
and the second set of points uh to the
orange cluster
are the points down
so intuitively
we want to assign nearby points to the
same cluster
and you can kind of see that these
points are closer to each other and
these points are closer to the other end
some separation
clusters here
so more formally the task of clustering
is we're given some training points uh d
train and this is the list of points
under xn
and the output is an assignment of each
point to a cluster
formally
we have an assignment vector z
which is going to be here z1
all the way through zn
where each zi
is an element from there's a number
between one
and k
so assuming we have big k clusters
each point is assigned to one of the
so
what makes a cluster
the key assumption behind
k-means
is that each cluster can be represented
faithfully by a centroid
and we're going to concatenate all the
centers together to form uh
so this diagram illustrates what a
centroid is trying to capture
the centroid is in some sense
a point which is closest to all the
other points on in that clusters
represents a cluster by some concrete
point in space
centroid
so the intuition in terms of centroid is
that we want
each point
to be close to its assigned centroid u
of z i's a bit of notation which i'll go
through later but intuitively you can
look at this point over here
we want this point to be close to
um the centroid of the sine cluster
and this point
goes to centroid
so now we can define the k-means
objective function
here's a picture which i walk through so
the k-means objective function is uh
denoted as a loss
he means loss function
and it's a function of the cluster
assignments um
one through zn
and the
cluster centroids mu1 through
and this is equal to i'm going to look
at all the endpoints
some over them
looking at the
i point
look at the difference between
um
so zi is
uh one a number between one and k which
specifies which cluster
a point i is assigned to
and i'm going to access
its uh centroid
and i'm going to take a difference
between these two and uh square it so
this is the square difference between
distance between uh the point and its
okay so
pictorially what i'm looking at is for
each point i look at its uh
assigned centroid
and i'm looking at the squared
of the length of these dashed uh lines
sum of all the squares of the dashed
lines is exactly
amy plus
i have to be as small as possible so i
want to minimize with respect to both
the clusters centroids the cluster
assignments and the centroids
of this objective function
so
this is to get some intuition
let's consider a simpler example in one
dimension so here we have four points at
0
2
um 10 and 12.
okay so
i'm going to consider
the
the case of if we know what the
centroids are does that make our life
easier
so if we know the centroids are at one
and eleven
um indeed this becomes a pretty trivial
problem because now remember how do we
assign points well
for the first point we just assign it to
the closest centroid
because where we know where the
centroids are
um so this point is zero is closest to
one so i'm going to assign this one
for z2
this point is closest to one so
one
this point is closest to plus the
century for cluster two
and same with
this so all i'm doing is
looking at all the centroids and
one is the closest to
the point i'm trying to assign
so now let's consider the case where i
don't know
centroids
but i have the assignments
if i have the assignments
then i can also compute the centroid
so for the first cluster
i simply look at all the points that are
assigned to that cluster
and remember i want to find
the centroid which is as close as
possible to all the mount average and so
this is going to be minimum over
sum of the squared distances
and recall that that is exactly
optimized in closed form by sending it
to mean
of
the points assigned to that cluster
so for mere two
um points 10 and 12 are assigned to that
cluster so the mean of those is 11.
so now
given either the cluster
assignments
or the centroids we can successfully
recover the
optimally
but this is a chicken and egg problem
because we neither have
the centroids nor do we have the
assignments to begin with
so what can we do
well
um let's just uh take a gamble and just
initialize randomly
okay so we're going to initialize
the the centroids to some random
so let's us usually they are assigned to
uh some of the existing points data
points so let's just assign them to
so clearly this is not optimum
but let's try to iterate to
so first iteration
what we're going to do
is we're going to fix these centroids
and optimize the cluster assignments so
let's look at each point and try to
assign it to one of these clusters
so zero is closest to zero so i'm going
to assign that
plus a one
this point
two is closest to cluster two because
it's right on top so that's two
and these two points
are also closest to
um
uh cluster two so they'll annotate them
assign them to cluster two
and then i'm going to use these uh new
assignments and try to re-estimate the
centroid
so for the first cluster
i'm just going that's only this point so
i'm going to keep the
centroid there
and for the second cluster now i have uh
these three points and i'm going to
find a
place the centroid that minimizes the
square distance to all of them which is
going to be the average at eight
which is two plus ten plus twelve
divided by three
okay so now i have these uh updated
centroids at zero and eight you can see
that this is looking a bit better
and now the second iteration i'm going
to
um reassign the points
based on these uh plus new centroids is
thrown in
so um the first
at this point is going to be assigned to
cluster
right here
um this point is uh is also going to be
close assigned to cluster 1 because 0 is
closer to 2 than this
and uh
point 10 is going to be closest to
the second cluster
and same with point
so now we have new cluster assignments
we can go back and uh re-estimate the
centroids
and now we're back in our familiar uh
problem from the previous slide where
we look at the first cluster
the sine
of the centroid to be just the mean
between the two points
and same
second cluster
and then 12 is 11.
and now we're actually converged
um if you try to repeat this process
nothing will change so we're done
and in this case it happens to recover
the optimum
clustering for these four points even
though we didn't know anything to start
out with
so here is the k-means algorithm stated
more formally
so
first we are going to initialize all the
centroids randomly
then we're going to iterate
d times or until convergence
and we're going to alternate between
step one which is set the assignments
given the centroids and step two which
is setting the centroids given
assignments
so step one we're going to go through
each point
and we're going to try to assign it and
assign it to zi is going to be
equal to
we're going to look at all the
the clusters
1 through big k
for each one of these we're going to
look at where that point is
and
look at the square distance between
the centroid of that cluster
squared
and then we're just going to take the
argument which is the cluster
k which minimizes this
for step two we're going to loop over
all the clusters
and we're going to set the centroid for
that cluster to be
um we're going to
look at all of the points i which are
assigned
to that cluster okay
and just uh average um sum up all the
uh the points
and this one divided by the number of
points i'm summing over to get the
average
um
equals k
okay so that is the k-means algorithm
so one word about whether it
works or not the k-means algorithm is
guaranteed to converge to a local
minimum of the objective k-means
objective
but it's not guaranteed to converge uh
to find the global minimum it's a
cartoon picture of all optimization
functions it can convert to a local
minimum but not a global
um so here if you click here i have this
demo
which shows you
how k-means works um
so you can actually construct your own
set of training examples and if you
step through the k-means algorithm
um you initialize and
it
alternate between moving these centroids
around and reassigning the points
and in this happy case we actually get
to a pretty good clustering um the blue
points over here red points over here
and green
training error
means objective function is 44.7
um but if i initialize in slightly
different way
um let's see what happens
uh it converges to something with much
worse error and you can see visually
that this is a sub-optimal clustering
because this point has only one
this cluster only has one point whereas
this cluster has so many other points
which are spread out
so um what do you do about
this um
well there are a couple things
one is that you can just run them
multiple times for different
randomizations
and take the best one
another thing you can do is use a
smarter heuristic so i didn't say very
much about
initialization
but you there's a cool thing you can do
called k-means plus plus where you
initialize the clusters one at a time
the centroids one at a time to be the
data points which are as far away as
possible from all the other so this kind
of makes sure that the centroids are
spread out and that they can kind of
move over time to capture all the points
in your content
okay to wrap things up so far we've
talked about k-means which is an
algorithm for doing clustering and
clustering is a useful task
that can be allowed to discover a
structure and non-labeled data
particularly group points together it's
useful to distinguish k-means um
two
meanings of k-means
the first is the k-means objective
so this is objective function that says
find assignments and find centroids that
minimizes
the squared distance between
each point and a side the centroid of
the sine cluster
and then there's a k-means algorithm
which performs alternating minimization
on the k-means objective
uh so
this is a
setting the assignments given the
centroids and setting the centroids
given assignments
chicken egg problem so this is not
guaranteed to
globally minimize the k-means objective
although
and can usually get pretty good results
robustly
um step me back a little bit
a means is for clustering there's other
types of clustering methods
out there and clustering is a form of
unsupervised learning
and
generally unsupervised learning has a
few use cases one is just data
exploration and discovery to get a pile
of data you might not have had a chance
to
annotate or label it
so you can run clustering or other types
of unsupervised learning to
group points and discover any sort of
structure
to get insight
and the second use case is that when you
perform clustering or some sort of
representation learning you can actually
get useful
representations or features that you can
stick them in to downstream supervised
learning problems when you do get a
bunch of label data and this generally
is helpful for
helping
supervised learning work better
okay so that's end of this module